problemas en palacio la familia real
jordana hachemita vive horas
desconcertantes más de una decena de
personas fueron detenidas este sábado
entre las que se incluyen un miembro de
la familia real y un ex ministro y ex
asesor del rey abdalá el motivo sería
una presunta conspiración y detrás
estaría el príncipe heredero hans a
quien denunció estar bajo arresto
domiciliario en un complot en contra
suya no formo parte de ninguna
conspiración espero que los jordanos
sean lo suficientemente maduros como
para no creer ninguna narrativa que
pueda surgir sobre estos hechos el
príncipe hans a se convirtió en heredero
tras la muerte del rey hussein en 1999
un cargo que le retiró el actual rey
abdalá en 2004 la reina noor una de las
esposas que tuvo hussein es la madre de
hamza y salió en su defensa orando para
que la verdad y la justicia prevalezca
en para todas las víctimas inocentes de
este malvado complot jamás ha tenido un
papel crítico contra el estado jordano
es cercano a los generar grupos
opositores que suelen denunciar la
corrupción
también se le acusa de tratar de buscar
alianzas foráneas una agencia de
inteligencia extranjera habría ofrecido
un avión para que hansa saliera con su
mujer del país
el viceprimerministro aseguró que se ha
tratado de solucionar el conflicto
dentro de la familia real pero hamza
estaría desestabilizando el país oeste
claro las investigaciones monitorearon
la interferencia y las llamadas
incluidas las llamadas con partes
extranjeras sobre el momento adecuado
para comenzar a tomar medidas para
sacudir la seguridad de nuestra firme
jordania opositores han dado su apoyo a
hamza mientras que el rey abdalá cuenta
con el apoyo del ejército así como de
potencias mundiales como estados unidos
jordania ha sido un oasis de estabilidad
en el convulso medio oriente sin embargo
la gestión del cobi 19 y la corrupción
estarían despertando cada vez más voces
críticas